thirteen billion years ago the universe
uses gravity to fuse atoms instead of an
electrical cage
across the cosmos vast clouds of
hydrogen gas collapse under their own
gravity
pressure and temperature build as more
and more gas gets sucked in eventually
fusion sparks deep in the core of these
giant balls of gas and the first stars
start to manufacture many of the heavy
elements that make up your car today
a star is basically a machine for
turning lighter elements into heavier
elements fusion takes place only inside
the core of these first stars fusing
hydrogen atoms together to create helium
and when all the hydrogen in the core is
used up the star finds new fuel to burn
after you burn hydrogen to form helium
the core of the star begins to collapse
and get hotter and there is enough
energy then to fuse three helium nuclei
into carbon and then that fuses to form
nitrogen oxygen silicon iron but this
incredible production line of elements
can't go on forever the heavier atoms
you rammed together the less energy you
get out so you turn hydrogen into helium
helium becomes carbon nitrogen oxygen
but every time there's a bit less energy
to be had until you get to iron the iron
that is in your car is actually
essentially a deadly poison when it
comes to a star it's robbing that star
of the heat needed to keep itself up
so the star collapses dies and explodes
at the moment you create iron in the
core I mean literally the fraction of a
second I'm not kidding
that's how dramatic and weird the steel
in your car is the explosion called a
supernova is one of the brightest and
most violent events in the universe it
releases enough energy to dwarf what the
Sun puts out over its entire lifetime
and all of the elements that it is
created are then dispersed out into
space the gassy remains of the explosion
are called
a supernova remnant an expanding bubble
of hydrogen gas from the outer layers of
the star that mixes with Stardust the
carbon oxygen silicon and fire from its
core
and this same 13 billion year old
Stardust helped you drive to work last
week